a series of events called the menstrual
cycle happens about once every month to
prepare a woman's body for pregnancy
changing levels of natural chemicals in
the bloodstream called hormones control
these events the reproductive organs
affected by these hormones include the
vagina
cervix
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
the ovaries produce two main hormones
called estrogen and progesterone as the
level of estrogen begins to rise it
causes the normally thick mucus inside
the cervix to thin out
estrogen also triggers other hormones to
cause one of the ovaries to release an
egg this process is called ovulation
if a woman has sex during this time a
man's reproductive cells called sperm
can pass through the thinner mucus to
fertilize an egg
in the uterus estrogen causes the lining
to thicken which prepares it to receive
a fertilized egg
rising progesterone levels cause glands
in the lining to release fluid that
feeds the fertilized egg
progesterone also causes the thinned-out
mucus in the cervix to become thick
again which prevents sperm from passing
through
if an egg hasn't been fertilized the
levels of both estrogen and progesterone
begin to fall this drop in hormone
levels causes menstruation a process
where the uterus sheds its inner tissue
lining and blood through the vagina
an intrauterine device or IUD is a birth
control method consisting of a soft
flexible t-shaped device with a thin
string on the end
there are two types of intrauterine
devices hormonal IUDs and a copper IUD
to prevent pregnancy a doctor places an
IUD inside a woman's uterus with the
string hanging down inside her vagina
both types of IUD cause mild
inflammation of the uterine lining
which releases immune cells and
chemicals that kill sperm
hormonal IUDs also contain a synthetic
type of progesterone called
levonorgestrel
levonorgestrel mainly prevents pregnancy
by thickening the mucus inside the
cervix which prevents sperm from
entering the uterus
it also prevents the uterine lining from
thickening so it is less likely to
receive a fertilized egg
about a month after inserting an IUD the
doctor may schedule an exam to make sure
it is still in place
dr. may also teach the woman how to
check her IUD between visits by feeling
for the string inside the vagina
depending on the type an IUD can be left
in place for 3 to 10 years women can
have their doctor remove an IUD at any
time for any reason including the desire
to have children
an intrauterine device or IUD is one of
the most effective methods of birth
control
IUDs are over 99% effective at
preventing pregnancy
this means that less than one out of a
hundred women will become pregnant each
year if they use an IUD and check it
regularly for correct placement
however IUDs are only about 97%
effective if not checked for correct
placement
for more information on any type of
birth control talk to your doctor